[Musique]
bonjour line on revient avec vous sur
cette décision de la russie de coupé les
livraisons de gaz à la pologne et à la
bulgarie et ce dès aujourd'hui deux pays
qui sont dépendants du gaz russe comment
vont-ils faire alors c'est vrai ces pays
ont expliqué comment il allait faire
mais voyons d'abord le degré de
dépendance très importante pour la
bulgarie ou encore pour la pologne la
bulgarie par exemple reçoit plus de 90 %
du gaz qu'elle consomme qu'elle consomme
depuis la russie c'est environ 57% dans
le cas de la pologne donc on le voit ici
60% à peu près alors les compagnies
gazières nationales des deux pays ont
été informés mardi soir de la décision
de moscou gazprom a d'abord informé la
compagnie polonaise le gazier polonais
pge ng l'information est ensuite arrivé
à la compagnie et gazière bulgare
bulgargaz et les gouvernements des deux
pays n'ont pas tardé à réagir sofia
d'abord cherché à rassurer en parlant de
sources d'approvisionnement alternatives
un approvisionnement suffisant également
même chose de la part de varsovie qui
dit se préparer depuis des années a donc
cessé ses approvisionnements de la part
de la russie bien avant le début de la
guerre en ukraine en effet le contrat
qui est actuellement en cours entre
gazprom et la compagnie donc polonaise
arrive à échéance à la fin de l'année en
cours et donc varsovie cherche surtout à
développer ses approvisionnements depuis
la norvège avec un objectif pauline
arriver à 50 % de gaz qui provient donc
de norvège prochainement je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction de la ministre
polonaise du climat
nous sommes prêts à être totalement
coupée des ressources aux russes nous
avons imposé un embargo sur le charbon
le 16 avril nous sommes prêts pour une
coupure complète des importations de gaz
et de pétrole russe mais quand obinna
alors pour moscou ces deux pays ne
respectent pas les nouvelles modalités
de paiement des contrats ça consiste en
quoi exactement alors vous souvenez le
président russe vladimir poutine avait
annoncé le mois dernier son intention de
demander aux pays qu'ils jugent
inamicaux de payer les contrats de gaz
directement en roubles alors il s'agit
d'un mécanisme en deux étapes d'abord
les clients de gazprom donc les clients
qui achètent du gaz russe doivent payer
donc payer les factures en devises en
euros ou en dollars en les payant à la
banque de gazprom qui s'appelle
gazprombank il paye d'abord en devises
la banque gazprombank on va convertir
donc cet argent en roubles et l'argent
est ensuite transféré à à gazprom
problème pour les par exemple pour la
bulgarie pour l'ensemble des européens
aussi c'est qu'il n'y a aucune garantie
que en suivant cette procédure et bien
il y ait un livraison réel du gaz je
cite par exemple la réaction du
gouvernement bulgare pour qui cette
nouvelle procédure de paiement donc en
deux étapes n'est pas conforme au
contrat existant jusqu'à la fin de cette
année elle présente selon gouvernement
bulgare des risques importants notamment
celui d'effectuer des paiements donc
sans recevoir aucune livraison de gaz en
contrepartie à noter également un autre
élément en pauline c'est que si
aujourd'hui la pologne et la bulgarie
sont particulièrement touchés il ya bien
sûr des raisons politiques carmel a
évoqué tout à l'heure et puis il ya des
raisons techniques sur le papier c'est
parce que les prochaines factures de ces
deux pays arrivent à échéance bientôt
donc elles doivent être payées fin avril
et courant mai les regards se tournent
maintenant vers d'autres pays européens
comme l'allemagne et l'italie qui sont
eux aussi très dépendants du gaz russe
c'est vrai ces deux pays qui sont très
dépendants du gaz russe sont aussi deux
poids lourds de l'économie européenne
vous le savez l'allemagne la première
économie de la zone euro l'italie la
troisième économie de la zone euro et
s'est payé un portrait de la moitié de
leur gaz depuis la russie regardons
d'abord la situation pour l'italie
l'italie à la porte 45 % de son gaz
depuis la russie et ces dernières
semaines le gouvernement italien a
multiplié les manoeuvres diplomatiques
pour diversifier les sources
d'approvisionnement notamment en
provenance d'afrique des contrats ont
été donc nouer avec l'algérie l'egypte
la république du congo l'angola est une
visite est prévue donc dans le courant
du mois de mai au mozambique pour
essayer aussi de trouver un accord et
s'approvisionne même donc en gaz naturel
liquéfié et puis du côté de l'allemagne
la dépendance est aussi grande au gaz
russe près de 55 % donc du gaz allemand
provenant de russie avant la guerre en
ukraine cette dépendance à la été
réduite très rapidement après le début
de la guerre on serait à 40%
actuellement avec un objectif
d'atteindre 30% d'ici la fin de l'année
alors le défi de l'allemagne si elle
cherche à diversifier ses sources
d'approvisionnement
c'est donc de pouvoir recevoir le gaz
naturel liquéfié parce qu'une fois qu'on
l'importent ils font donc leur
transformé en gaz il faut des terminaux
pour cela l'allemagne cherche donc à
s'équiper c'est un défi et qu'a
mentionné le ministre allemand de
l'économie on les fout tu
nous travaillons sous pression pour
réduire la dépendance de l'allemagne aux
gaz russe et nous développons nos
capacités d'importation de gaz naturel
liquéfié à présent la dépendance à la
russie s'est considérablement réduite et
puis si l'allemagne continue de
s'approvisionner pour le moment en gaz
russe tout le défi police est de savoir
si elle peut à court terme sans passer
pour le moment le risque c'est de voir
les prix flamber avec des tensions
inflationnistes encore plus importante
que les tensions actuelles ou le sait
ces problématiques pour l'allemagne un
pays dont le secteur industriel
l'industrie manufacturière est très
importante on le ressent déjà à travers
la confiance donc et dans le monde des
affaires une confiance en baisse et un
pessimisme vis-à-vis de la situation
actuelle merci line pour